evening and welcome to tucker carl's
inside happy friday
if there's one thing we have learned
about the people who make the rules it's
that they have no intention of following
them any of them ever
ever they command you to wear a mask as
you jog alone in the park while they
head to dinner bare-faced at the french
laundry that happened
they harangue of the carbon footprint of
your lawnmower as they fly to aspen on
their private jets
you see that every day how many members
of congress who voted to expand the
police powers of the irs don't pay their
own taxes
more than a few
how many politicians who fervently
support gun control have armed
bodyguards that you pay for well let's
see every single one we could go on and
on and on whatever they're demanding
that you do this week you can be dead
certain they are not doing it themselves
everyone notices this it enrages people
but it's often misinterpreted people say
this is hypocrisy but it's not
it's privilege
when nancy pelosi walks into her hair
appointment without a mask at the height
of the coveted lockdowns it's not
because she forgot to bring a mask no
she knows exactly what she's doing nancy
pelosi is affirming her position in the
social order
nancy pelosi is in charge you are not
nancy pelosi can do whatever she cares
to do you can't
that's the message she's sending
another word for this is a caste system
which is increasingly what we have in
the united states caste systems are
common in poor countries the countries
from which most of our immigrants come
but it's the opposite of the traditional
american system which was imperfect
egalitarianism
in the old america every citizen citizen
was considered equal under the law as
well as in the eyes of god everybody had
to follow the same rules because nobody
underneath it all was more important
than anyone else we were all citizens
citizens is a term you rarely hear
anymore citizenship implies inherent
rights rights that politicians cannot
under any circumstances take from you
because they did not bestow them in the
first place you were born with them
but the people running our country don't
acknowledge this they do not believe in
inherent rights nor do they believe in
equality
you may remember how hysterical they
became a couple of years ago when a few
old-fashioned souls dared to say that
all lives matter which they certainly do
the people in charge hated that they
don't think that all lives matter in
their view some animals are more equal
than others
it's hard to think of a news story in
recent memory that illustrates this
phenomenon as clearly as what is
happening on martha's vineyard
two nights ago governor ron desantis of
florida generously sent a plane load of
50 illegal aliens from venezuela to the
vineyard which is a small famously
affluent island off the coast of
massachusetts
martha's vineyard has everything you
could ever want in the world except
racial diversity the island is whiter
than a swedish bluegrass festival and
desantis was trying to help
under normal circumstances the residents
of martha's vineyard would have no
choice but to smile and say thank you
governor desantis
when government officials send you the
blessed gift of diverse immigrants or
refugees you must accept that's the rule
it doesn't matter how disruptive these
new people are it's irrelevant how much
they cost to support or how dramatically
your quality of life may decline after
they arrive it doesn't matter if the
crime rate spikes if your daughter's
afraid to go outside if the schools
become unusable the hospitals fall apart
doesn't matter you never complain you
take it like a man
you don't even mention it's happening
even in private text messages to your
friends if you do you're a dangerous
racist you could wind up on a government
list
that's how america works everybody knows
it because it's been going on for a very
long time that's the rule
but it turns out the people of martha's
vineyard aren't just anyone they're the
people who make the rules
and in this case they had no intention
of following them not even for a day
the venezuelans who arrived there two
nights ago bless their hearts didn't
know any of this they had no perspective
they never heard of martha's vineyard
they was thrilled to be there watch
i can't tell you they are not angry at
ron desantis they are actually thanking
him for having brought them to martha's
vineyard
well yeah they're not angry at mark ron
desantis they're thanking him for
bringing them to martha's vineyard why
wouldn't they they got a flea free
flight to the vineyard
and at first it seemed like they had
every reason to be grateful because the
people of the town appeared to welcome
them as they walked in from the airport
three and a half miles they saw signs
like this one on martha's vineyard the
sign reads we stand with immigrants with
refugees all are welcome here hate has
no business here
in other words no one worked for donald
trump can go to martha's vineyard
but they didn't know that there was a
caveat to that welcome
haters not welcome here okay then on
thursday an elected official on the
island gave the migrants even more
reason for hope and we're quoting this
is a community rallying to support
immigrant children and families said
state representative dylan fernandez
it's the best of america
and then to prove his point that
martha's vineyard will do whatever it
can for immigrants fernandez uploaded
this picture onto social media because
of course everything is a social media
opportunity the picture shows several
venezuelans gathered on a porch one of
them is wearing a shirt celebrating ruth
bader ginsburg notorious rbg it says
clearly he got that from a local
but then you look closely and you ask
yourself are these people really welcome
on martha's vineyard what are they
eating
there's no kale or breed for the
venezuelans no instead they got corn
pops
froot loops rice krispies with a side of
paper plates and napkins
you got to wonder what the venezuelans
thought of that
this seems like a nice place the food is
garbage
it's less healthy than the crap we eat
in caracas way worse why are they
feeding us this stuff corn pops really
fruit loops what message are you sending
and of course the message was really
clear
the surfs eat garbage
i think what do they eat what are the
what is your average venezuelan eat
i don't know froot loops
venezuelans love froot loops
so the venezuelans may have gotten a
hint that they weren't really welcome
there
but it was hard to know the community
seemed to be rallying behind them but
then if there was any doubt in the
morning it was gone by afternoon because
the message changed very quickly and the
new message was get the hell out of here
brown people
the difficult challenges are
we don't have the services
to take care of 50 immigrants um and
we certainly don't have housing we're in
a housing crisis as we are on this
island and so
we don't we can't house everyone here
that lives here and works here we don't
have housing for 50 more people
we don't have housing for 50 more people
says the lady on an island that
literally has more than a hundred
thousand empty beds at that exact moment
because it's a seasonal place
and more than a hundred
seasonal residents are gone
so effectively martha's vineyard was the
largest dormitory in the united states
but no there's a housing crisis at some
point they're gonna have to leave
meaning in like eight minutes max
so there was a guy who's a leader of a
non-profit group
who stepped up to help the refugees and
he had a different take he said the
problem wasn't the housing at all it was
the migrants and we're quoting now
it's like me taking my trash out and
just driving to different areas where i
live and throwing my trash there
this man told nbc news
oh
they're trash they're human garbage
they're not even real they have no souls
do they have souls venezuelans do
refugees have souls i don't know there's
like trash someone dump them on the
front lawn
let's give them fruit loops and get them
out of here
yeah call the truck have him hauled away
nbc news actually tweeted out that quote
calling our beloved sacred immigrant
community these non-documented
immigrants trash and then once they
realized that they revealed how they
really feel they deleted a few moments
later
now not everyone on the left we should
tell you was so intent on sending these
migrants away novelist jane chidik for
example offered this alternative quote i
would love to see the obamas open up
their huge property and erect tents and
look after all these people while
they're being processed she said
well actually you know we're always in
search of the one decent liberal left in
america maybe jane chitick is the one
because that's a pretty fair point
and barack obama has a long documented
history of having people on his front
lawn in fact he set up a tent city to
house hundreds of people for let's see
oh himself his own birthday party so
could he do that again of course
and he should because to do anything
less than that barack obama himself told
us
would essentially punish the people of
martha's vineyard
mistreating immigrants would rob them of
what makes america a worthy country
watch this
america is a nation of immigrants
that's our strength
and the notion that
somehow we would stop now
on what has been a tradition of
attracting
talent and strivers and dreamers from
all around the world
that would
rob us of the thing that is most special
about america
right
so if people don't camp out on your lawn
people have no right to be here in the
first place you're only hurting yourself
but obama even on martha's vineyard
where approximately a hundred percent of
people voted for him and love him even
at martha's vineyard he could not make
the sale he could not get people who
actually live there
to agree with that
they did do one thing though they said a
big gofundme which they called an urgent
plea
and they told us this was a way to help
the migrants and we're quoting
from gofundme martha's vineyard is a
community of open-hearted individuals
that view these migrants as people not
political pawns or trash
however continuing the quote the island
is a resort community with only 20 000
year-round residents and it already
faces a shortage of affordable housing
and off-season jobs
oh it's just not rich enough they don't
have enough beds it's one of the richest
places in the united states and it has
more available beds than any other place
probably in north america right now
but it's just they can't swing it but
you can do your part by donating
to the fund
and by donating the fund they'll help
the migrants a lot of people
believed it
the fund raised forty thousand dollars
but here's the best part you're going to
love this part how much that money is
going to the migrants
oh none
none
an update on the fundraising page
reveals that the funds will instead go
toward we're quoting building up a
reserve to assist situations like this
in the future rather than directly
helping this group of migrants in their
situation in other words
martha's vineyard is building itself an
endowment
just like harvard
that's amazing
an endowment for martha's vineyard not
to help anyone but because why wouldn't
martha's vineyard want an endowment
who okay
well yesterday at the request of
martha's vineyard's representatives
they broke it up the governor of
massachusetts the thoroughly loathsome
charlie baker called up the national
guard charlie baker mr compassion
literally brought in the army to remove
brown people from the whitest island in
the atlantic ocean
so once the army brought them off
martha's vineyard they were sent to a
military base on cape cod a military
base how welcoming
cape cod by the way is a lot more
republican than martha's vineyard so
let's send them to them so here's the
scene of the migrants being escorted out
after less than 48 hours
on that jewel in the sea martha's
vineyard
thank you so much for being here
everyone as we're going to show you as
we as we're leaving you today a live
look in massachusetts we're showing the
the ferry carrying migrants who have
been dropped in mass in martha's
vineyard have arrived in cape cod that
bus you see there that is heading to
joint base cape cod
well you got to say they don't mess
around the liberals aren't joking so the
rest of the country just pick a city
pick a city in the country and ask the
person after a few drinks who runs it
like how many refugees do you have
living here how many
migrants many of them undocument how
many illegal aliens are living in your
city and what does that do to the
services in your town
not one of them is as rich as martha's
vineyard and they basically will tell
you we just have to live with it no one
wants to use the schools anymore the
hospitals are a complete mess or crime
rate is up the city looks like crap but
there's nothing we can do the government
sent them here oh but martha's vineyard
they don't play they bring in the army
in a day
and take him out like the garbage
so there's a lot of irony here and we're
going to try to unpack it as quickly and
crisply as we can but it was just a day
ago that we were told that ron desantis
was a human trafficker he was in fact
comparable to adolf hitler said ken
burns america's filmmaker because he had
organized the transportation of migrants
from his state to martha's vineyard
watch
this is so cruel and and so unnecessary
so uncalled for and so brazen uh it
shocks the conscience of any fair-minded
human being this tactic
by supposedly christian-right
politicians like desantis arizona's doug
ducey and greg abbott of texas is about
as unchristian as it gets stephanie that
is not a political stunt that is an act
of evil and it is an act of evil being
done by evil men some politicians would
rather not only have an issue but
exacerbate it to the extent of literally
human trafficking as you said and
sending them to destinations because you
want to own in a country where a woman
with a fetus inside of her with no brain
has to travel a thousand miles
to get an abortion look here is short
ron desantis and frankly greg abbott and
doug ducey we hate immigrants get the f
out and we will help you get the f out
these people
morning joe literally had the chipmunk
on to talk about how it's humic
trafficking
and then his lady has to get a boy
there's not enough abortion by the way
who mentioned abortion i don't know mika
wants more abortion okay mika settle
down
now these exact same people
are applauding
massachusetts for using the military to
remove
undesirable immigrants trash
trash they promised to safeguard to a
military base i mean what
is anyone noticing this
what's interesting is that this has been
going on in other forms for quite a
while for several months now the
governor of texas has sent bus loads of
migrants from the border to places like
dc and chicago it got some attention we
kind of enjoyed it but most people
didn't notice but the second brown
people arrive in martha's vineyard whoa
swarms of reporters descended on the
scene because they've been there before
yeah they know martha's vineyard they
don't know a ton about the south side of
chicago brownsville what but martha's
vineyard are you joking
cnn reported there was pandemonium
this is the location this is the one
uh homeless shelter that they have on
the entire island there are five
different towns here saint andrews
parish house can usually handle 10
they've had to increase the number to 50
of immigrants who will be here after
they were sort of unceremoniously
dropped
off on planes two different planes
in martha's vineyard
look at the glasses on that guy are the
glasses on tv people getting more
complex by the day or is it just
something old the old among us imagine
in any case just put in some perspective
before we proceed this is 50 people
50 people we've had two
million people come here
illegally where did they go well they
went to probably every state in the
country
dubai demonstration flew them there to
change the demographics of america
forever that's just true sorry
and no one said a word but 50 people
it's chaos in martha's vineyard
so why is only ron desantis a human
trafficker
for doing this
why is ron why is only ron desantis a
human trafficker for doing this
it's interesting
according to gavin newsom he's a
kidnapper
why did no one say that about greg
abbott or charlie baker or joe biden for
that matter as we've said for more than
a year the bite administration has flown
illegal migrants throughout the country
often in the middle of the night we
showed you footage of these flights
they're happening in secret secretly
flying people around the country isn't
that what the cartels do
but biden
is doing it and by the way to his credit
he said he would do it during the
presidential campaign he promised to
relocate migrants throughout the u.s in
fact he announced that america has room
for
millions and millions of illegal
migrants watch this we could afford to
take in a heartbeat another 2 million
people
the idea that a country of
330 million people
cannot absorb
people who are in desperate need and who
are justifiably fleeing oppression is
absolutely bizarre
absolutely bizarre
yeah it's bizarre you're a bigot if
you're not into it by the way again just
for perspective the one thing that
should never be partisan
is immigration policy because
immigration policy is the one policy
that's irreparable it changes your
country forever so you should have a
broad consensus about what you want your
country to become before you tamper with
the formula
but someone like joe biden who is only
partisan that's it
doesn't care
by the way what happened after biden
transported
all these people around the country
hundreds and hundreds of thousands well
in one community in florida florida a
community that can quote afford more
legal migrants a 24 year old honduran
man ended up murdering a father in his
own home that was in jacksonville
so that didn't get a ton of attention
but apparently people in martha's
vineyard were watching
they don't want that
and that's why the minute biden's voters
have to deal with venezuelan seeking the
american dream they call on the national
guard to ship them to military
installations as florida's governor said
yesterday this really does have to end
and all those people in dc and new york
were beating their chess when trump was
president saying they were so proud to
be sanctuary jurisdictions saying how
bad it was to have a secure border the
minute even a small fraction of what
those border towns deal with every day
is brought to their front door they all
of a sudden go berserk and they're so
upset that this is happening if you have
folks that are inclined to think
florida's a good place our message to
them is we are not a sanctuary state and
it's better to be able to go to a
sanctuary jurisdiction and yes we will
help facilitate that transport for you
to be able to go to greener pastures
yeah greener pastures aspen next
and by the way every ivy league college
all seven of them
and then maybe you hit wesleyan in
bowdoin and stanford
the places that support a ball above all
other institutions in this country that
support illegal immigration
that have more funding per capita than
any other institution in the united
states or the richest places in america
are college campuses liberal arts
college elite liberal arts colleges how
many migrants and refugees are they
taking zero
let's hope the next stop in this process
is there
and let's also hope that the governors
of sane states are watching how
democrats handled this within 24 hours
of having immigrants dumped on their
shores the people of martha's vineyard
had the military move them out
why is nobody else doing that
true
there's no longer any reason that
republicans shouldn't do that this is
the template
in texas arizona florida etc they should
do the exact same thing subscribe to the
fox news youtube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
tucker carlson tonight